why'd you get divorced he's not uh
confident enough for me he wasn't
confident enough for you what the does
that
mean we have so much criticism for men
we've lived in a society that has told
men to basically be defective women but
we never look in the mirror and ask are
we the perfect feminine
women no of course we're not he worked
all day he made good money he supported
us um I mean yeah we had our problem s
but he was the good guy so I'm here to
tell
you say don't leave say don't leave the
good guy at least learn from your
mistake please it's okay to leave
this what up guys welcome to the just
cly things YouTube channel and welcome
to my reaction series today I am going
to be reacting to he was a perfect
husband but something was missing so I
left I can't imagine what this is going
to be I am sure it is going to be an
abundance of abuse and just terrible
things that this guy did um that really
really made leaving a lifelong
commitment and vow with God makes sense
I'm sure this is going to be super
reasonable make sure you guys like the
video um and also get yourself a women
shouldn't vote t-shirt before we start
let's get started married for 10 years I
got married young I was 21 barely like 3
days
21 I left the a good guy he looks at and
is like that's a dad that's a husband
that's how it's supposed to be he did
the dishes he cleaned the house he took
the kids to school he worked oh so she
had kids so she she must have had a
really good reason I'm waiting I'm
waiting he made good money he supported
us why'd you get divorc it's not uh
confident okay
so he wasn't confident enough for you
what the f does that mean who's your
ideal man if you could be with any man
in the world who would it be I haven't
found him yet you haven't found him yet
damn you're so confident you need a man
on Pluto or
something trust me when they get to the
point where you're like oh sugar I've
actually lost a good guy here then they
that's when hit it's so funny and then I
always hear women don't divorce for no
reason and we'll be like exhibit a
exhibit B Exhibit C and what all they
say but what did he do to deserve to be
divorced to deserve to lose access to
his children children to deserve to lose
all of his money he did the dishes
apparently let me tell y'all something
sis stop breaking up with your
man if you married stop threatening that
man with the divorce every time he do
something so
small if he gave you a guilt-free pass
to sleep with anybody in the world would
you use
it
yeah on
who please don't say your ex-boyfriend
please don't say I've seen a couple of
these please please say anybody but your
ex-boyfriend Zach
Efron
Bowman some
celebrity celebrity you can't just pick
women based on looks you have well at
least she didn't say her ex-boyfriend I
mean not that that's you know poor guy
poor guy understand a woman's mindset
and if her mindset is modern
you got based on her own words her
ex-husband was a perfect man but she
still felt like something was missing
therefore she left him now she is a
single mother navigating the DAT life is
not all about being happy and that's the
biggest mistake we make as women we are
unhappy with ourselves and we think that
we can derive happiness from another
person and no guy is going to give you
the Fulfillment that you want in life
you know life isn't just about
relationships it's not like life isn't
your marriage is not going to make you
happy you have to become a happy person
or be a happy person so many times
people that are miserable think they can
get married and just be happy is that
how it works all right what if it was
all the way
around I know what I'm worth one night
with one celebrity doesn't change who I
am wow you wouldn't use it even if I
gave it to you no cuz it's it it sounds
like a
trap if if if you're significant others
yeah he should dump her give you one
night you can see it in this man's face
the level of disappointment that he has
in his lady's answer but even through
that silent hurt he gives an authentic
answer instead of one that he thinks
will also hurt her so it is clear that
this is a good man and he 100% deserves
better she clearly doesn't respect or
value him but he is the one who is
allowing this type of situation to
happen why is he still around someone
who doesn't care about his feelings she
already told him where he stand yeah men
adapt the market Unfortunately they
shouldn't but men do adapt I mean
they've accepted non virgins they've
accepted fat chicks they're now
accepting only fans models it is
actually crazy the level that men are
now willing to accept her life but he
still believes that he can change her
mind and this is where guys get it wrong
I mean that that's why the red pill
exists guys because a lot of times men
get married to women like that and then
have no idea what happened when she
leaves takes the kids in the house not
uncommon we have to know when we should
give up and we must let it go when we
have to he knows who she is but he
thinks that with time she will change
but I want you guys to understand that
when it comes to this level it's hard to
change this Dynamic I found some
interesting comments of this video let's
check them my wife would never cheat on
me we've been together since 1989 and
married for 31 years come this December
this woman just showed her true colors
wow what a nice genuine guy he deserves
better sorry brother but she is most
definitely not a keeper but she is a
future Runner cut her loose now and save
yourself the heartache and misery
because she's not worth it romantic love
doesn't exist love the person you're
with but don't fall for the fairy tale
relationship is over you can see the
Heartbreak in his face if this were me I
would walk away from her why'd you get
divorce it's not uh confident enough for
me he wasn't confident enough for you
what the fu does that
mean that would be like the harshest
thing anyone would ever say to me like I
got to break up with you you're not
confident enough
like oh I'm on my period now oh my go if
I asked my wife do you think I'm
confident she'd laugh that's what she
do she like no that's why well and the
thing is we we have so much criticism
for men right and we say they don't lead
well enough they don't take control
they're not masculine I mean none of
that's untrue we've lived in a society
that has told men that ain't [__] for
years that has told men to basically be
defective women so I'm not surprised
that we have a lack of masculinity and
Leadership but we never look in the
mirror and ask are we the perfect
feminine
women no of course we're not like you
know none of us are virgins anymore none
of us even really stick it out for a
lifetime anymore none us get married
young anymore so how are we going to
come at the men oh and we're really
overweight so how are we going to come
at the men when we don't even look in
the mirror ever ever for your
Brokenness I could never be with
you yeah I need to have my
self-deprecating little
strokes you need to [__] the rock or
something like that that's that's wild
how do you meet confident men Farmers
Only how do you meet a man you probably
go to the January 6 riots try to meet a
real confidence
who's your who's your ideal man if you
could be with any man in the world who
would it be I haven't found him yet you
haven't found him yet damn you're so
confident you need a man on Pluto or
something this is the first time I have
heard that a woman left her man because
he wasn't confident enough I honestly
wasn't expecting it and this is the
difference between the old generation
and the new one because currently we
leave relationships like it's nothing
there is no concern of how negatively it
will I think after the 70s most women
are the same I think there's a
difference in the generation before that
grew up in the' 60s 7s but after that it
was kind of done the overall family
after birth control women were working
like this isn't new this has been over
50 years of this the funny part is that
she is still searching for this
imaginary confident Prince Charming but
give it a few more years reality will
show her that he doesn't exist she
should be more realistic it's really sad
to see where we are as a generation and
how we view relationships we should be
willing to fight more for our
relationship it would be be better for
everyone women don't need a reason they
just level up when they can married for
10 years I got married young I was 21
barely like 3 days
21 um I already had a baby he was 8
weeks old at our
wedding
and I remember
feeling like
my marriage was temporary from the
beginning like that I wasn't going to
make it and I didn't know what that
feeling was I just thought it was so let
me get this straight she was married for
10 years strung this man along for 10
years had children with this man you
know women will always say I don't want
to waste my time yeah we are the queens
of wasting someone else's time let me
tell you if I could like women will go
on dates be like look I don't want to
waste I don't want to waste anyone's
time how many ex-boyfriends ex-husband's
time has been wasted here I knew from
the beginning that she didn't want to
marry
him marriage is forever and it's not
temporary and age is not an excuse in my
opinion but there's more to the story so
continue fighting for
me I was pushing him
away um but I I never truly accepted
happiness what does that mean what does
accepting happiness mean like we just
say things some sometimes we just say
these words we don't even know what they
mean we can't even quantify them like
what does happiness look like a single
mom on food stamps are you happy now
like the truth is happy people are happy
broke and they're happy Rich they're
just happy people you're either a happy
person or you're not happy um you know I
I some of the most depressed people ever
I've seen very rich very wealthy people
you are responsible for your happiness
not your husband your husband is not
responsible for making you happy that's
not his job I left the good guy he looks
at and is like that's a dad that's a
husband that's how it's supposed to be
he did the dishes he cleaned the house
he took the kids oh but you know there
was World War II on Twitter I have a
friend named Rachel she's married she's
got like four kids homeschooled them
Cooks but does the does the whole thing
this woman this woman said my husband
has never touched a dish takes pride in
that all of tradcon Twitter raged they
raged they said oh no oh no this this I
can't believe he doesn't do the dishes
so let me get this straight you guys you
guys want your husbands to not only
provide for you and protect you now they
also have to take you on date nights
weekly that was the other thing they
raged about and they also need to help
you with the chores all right all right
he worked all day he made good money he
supported us um I mean yeah we had our
problems but he was the good guy so I'm
here to tell you say don't leave say
don't leave the good guy at least learn
from your mistake please it's okay to
leave
the I'm speech you guys leave me
speechless I thought she would at least
be like guys learn from me women love to
lead other women down down the path of
Destruction what what about your
kids and she says something about
finding happiness and not being happy
but she doesn't realize is that a man
isn't the one that's going to make you
happy you have to make yourself happy so
she should have done a lot of self-work
within the relationship because you can
be in a relationship while
simultaneously working on yourself and
because she got married at 21 I'm sure
she missed out on her whole phase and
now she's going to be 31 as a single mom
out having fun because she missed out on
it as if that's going to be acceptable
going into her 40s and basically she
goes on to say how a guy can be a good
guy but not the right guy but here is my
thought process okay first of all you
knew that from the beginning and you're
not upfront or you did you communicate
that you wasted 10 years of this man's
life where he could have gone out and
found someone who appreciated him but
additionally now it's 10 years later if
she was 21 she's 31 now so now she's a
single mom at 31 and she's about to go
on the dating scene and she thinks
that's going to be better and that
there's good guys yeah that's my
question what do you think is on the
other side of this men are very clear
single mothers in general recreational
use only men are very clear about this
they do not want to take single mother
seriously they do not want to raise
another man's kids that is not what they
want to do left out there but this is
also what I talk about on this page
about these women they ruin the good
guys because now this man is going to go
get his heartbroken and and never be the
same ever again all because she knew
from the beginning and couldn't be
upfront about it like how sick and
twisted do you have to be to make a man
a placeholder and have children with him
and so many women in the comments right
now was like oh this is exactly my
situation I've been married for 11 years
and he's such a good guy and you know
but he's not for me y'all need to stop
listening to shitty advice on on the
internet like that and go into therapy
and CH this exactly exactly for your
marriages and fight for the good men
that that are out there cuz I can
promise you that the dating scene is not
any better but not only that they always
think that they watch some Tik Tok
videos they think the grass is greener
on the other side and then just go ruin
their lives this man is about to get all
his [__] wrecked when she already knew
from the beginning that he wasn't the
one in divorce he's about to lose half
and who knows his visit visitation you
know how a lot of women can be with the
visitation of their children and as soon
as they're pissed they give the silent
treatment there's so many things that
could happen in divorce that what she
didn't consider in the first place yeah
what about the kids like she kept
talking about her happiness it's like
these women I question do you even like
your children I swear some of these moms
they don't even like their kids because
their kids are the last ones that they
consult the last ones that they consider
in any decision if you guys really
enjoyed and loved your children what are
you doing I I I swear what are you doing
just despicable after this experience he
is probably feeling used and it can have
a huge impact which could change his
views of relationship yeah you know most
players are made they're not born most
men want I really think that men are
more traditional than women these days
more men want to settle down and do the
family thing than women we don't pick it
and this is another reason more and more
guys are becoming smarter when it comes
to dealing with their Partners I don't
know why she wasn't honest from the
start it seems like he was a placeholder
from the beginning and this is not fair
on him but I'm glad she did it now he
can find someone who deserves his love
she still doesn't know what she lost she
thought that Chads and Tyrone and her DM
were willing to play her husband's role
but she was so wrong yeah we we mistake
sexual attention for relationship
attention men will screw anything we
know this does not mean they want to
date you a few years we will have her
posting another video complaining about
how men ain't is let's jump into the
comment section because a lot of women
want a wedding not a merriage yeah
that's true they want a big extravagant
show for their friends to see like a
contest yeah it's so interesting we'll
spend like 15K you think about the trip
you could get with your husband for 15K
but we spend it on what one day for a
marriage that on average lasts eight
years I'm not happy so I'm taking half
of
your this is just a long way of saying
the streets were called calling me it
bothers me a lot to hear stories like
this people not being honest with
themselves or others and especially
taking good people for granted one of
the worst things you can do to a guy is
tell him that everything he did for you
for 10 years meant absolutely nothing
sounds like what my ex-wife did she even
told me the same things now she keeps
attacking me and interrupting my life
yeah yeah and the Ex-Wives are a
nuisance for a lifetime they just give
the these men a lifetime a problem even
when they're not married they're like I
thought I thought you wanted divorce why
are you still here why are you still
bothering me trust me when they get to
the point where you're like oh sugar
I've actually lost a good guy here then
they then that's when it hits that's
when it hits when you're like oh
actually I realized I've gone from this
guy I tried this guy they all up similar
and I had that one good guy but I left
him cuz he didn't drive cuz he didn't
drive let me tell youall something
sis stop breaking up with your man if
you married stop threatening that man
with divorce every time he do something
so
small y'all want to blow it up be ready
to throw the whole [__] away be ready
to throw your whole husband away knowing
good and goddamn well that's the best
man that y'all ever had in your whole
lifetime and then you walk around like
your [__] don't stink like you don't
come with flaws like you don't have
issues that flow out of your heart and
it's like come on man y'all on this
independ yeah and that's the thing I
think the biggest problem with women is
just we have extreme narcissism it's
everywhere because we have an entire
economy that profits off of making us
narcissistic the men don't want to tell
us the truth because we freak out when
they tell us the truth and they don't
get laid or that's and to them it's like
well if I tell them the truth I have to
deal with all these problems all these
bitching and whining not today and
nobody can tell us anything hi horse I
had everything before I met him I had my
[__] together but if you were so
independent then you take your single
ass over there and you be
lonely y'all cannot expect for men not
to make mistakes for men not to [__] up
we but you talking about somebody who is
the foundation of the house who is your
leader supposed to be your leader but
y'all too busy trying to be independent
I couldn't agree more but we all know
how they think they will know the value
of the man they had after losing him
modern women think that there is an
abundance of good single men ready to
marry them no most men aren't even
looking for marriage and relationships
any more we're really in a post-marriage
world ladies buckle up this will be an
interesting next 20 years and we this is
the problem we have women that are
throwing away good men thinking that the
grass is greener on the other side when
in general it's not it's really not so
and it ruins the next generation of men
because they saw their dads their
grandpas get screwed over in a divorce
they don't want to sign up for that and
that's why you have young men are not
looking for marriage and relationships
and sex the way they used to they're not
really approaching women like that
you're not really pursuing women like
that because they have found out through
the last 100 years that the juice really
has not been worth the squeeze but let
me know what you guys think in the
comments make sure you like the video on
your way out and subscribe to the
channel make sure you bring that
notification Bell and I'll talk to you
next time